the president and vice president said
asian americans have been unfairly
scapegoated during the past year of the
pandemic
as senior white house correspondent
wijja jang reports asian americans and
pacific islanders
have been the victims of thousands of
incidents of violence
and harassment mike nguyen was stunned
to see
this at his ramen shop in san antonio
texas
on sunday the words kung flu kami
and i hope you die covering the windows
i definitely believe that uh it's
definitely a hate crime
gwen said the vandalism came after he
publicly criticized texas governor greg
abbott's decision to lift a mask mandate
he's putting a lot of us in danger you
know
he's at a time where we need him to be a
leader he's not being a leader
a two-time cancer survivor when was
worried about his customer's health
now he's worried about his own the next
escalation is going to be
either physical harm or even something
fatal so
you know that's very worrisome for me so
you worry that
you could lose your life
yeah absolutely you know people have you
know threaten my life they say i hope
you die you know
people say that they want to find where
i live and
burn down my house the advocacy group
stop aapi hate has recorded nearly
4 000 crimes against asian americans
since the start of the pandemic
an increase of about 150 percent in
major u.s cities
this week alone a 76 year old
grandmother in san francisco
is recovering after fighting off her
attacker
and this 59-year-old man was brutally
beaten
nearly blinded in one eye too many
asian-americans have been walking
up and down the streets and worrying
waking up each morning
the past year feeling their safety and
the safety of their loved ones are at
stake
on friday president biden met with asian
american leaders in atlanta to talk
about solutions to combat the violence
that just claimed eight lives in their
city
including six asian women georgia state
legislature
michelle the last administration clearly
clearly promoted and fomented
a culture of anti-asian american and
anti-immigrant
animus now with the biden administration
he clearly is invested
in listening to this issue and thursday
on capitol hill
lawmakers held a hearing about the surge
in attacks
asian americans must not be used as
scapegoats in times
of crisis lives are at stake and it's
critical
that congress takes bold action to
address
this pandemic of discrimination and hate
texas congressman chip roy questioned if
a crime should be linked
to hate who decides what is hate
who decides what is the kind of speech
that deserves
policing roy also defended the use of
anti-chinese rhetoric to describe the
virus
i'm not going to be ashamed of saying i
oppose
the tricom new york congresswoman grace
mang
fired back this hearing was to address
the hurt and pain of our community
and to find solutions and we will not
let you take our voice away from us
mang introduced the coven 19 hate crimes
act after
racist voicemails flooded her
in los angeles denny kim heard similar
slurs while walking down a sidewalk last
month
they started calling me chinese virus
they started calling me they started
calling me
kim a korean american and a u.s air
force veteran
said the assault quickly turned physical
the assailants
when they were beating me up on the
ground they told me that they wanted to
kill me
now both he and when are pleading for
more protection
i think what needs to happen is more
awareness you know and and
actual charging people with hate crimes
showing that we're not gonna
this is not tolerable i feel like
president biden really needs to
protect asian americans right now if
you're listening to me
if you're watching this right now sir i
need you to help my people sir
because we're getting shot and killed
sir
president biden says he does support
congressman ming's covet 19
hate crimes act which would require a
faster federal response to review
and track all of these attacks meanwhile
a group of nearly 200 organizations is
calling on the white house
to provide 300 million dollars to help
the victims
and to give more resources to combating
this
violence jeff vice president harris said
people in positions of power with the
biggest pulpits
have been scapegoating asian americans
over the past year it's no secret she's
referring to former president trump
how did we get here you know jeff having
covered
the pandemic from day one um i tracked
the president's rhetoric and he wanted
to make the very clear argument that
this was not his fault and at one point
he even said he was going to stop
using phrases like chinese virus and
wuhan flew because of concern for the
asian american community
but then as the number of cases and as
the
death toll continued to rise he brought
that language back
because he wanted to make clear that
this was china's fault
even though there were so many warnings
that this was hurting the asian american
community and now members and victims
are telling me
they believe that gave other people a
path to do the same thing
to misplace the blame and to take out
their anger which we are all
feeling because it has been such a long
haul
on um you know innocent victims that
have nothing to do
with the virus i mean many of these
people are not even
chinese americans these are korean
americans these are japanese americans
they just
look vaguely asian and therefore are
being targeted
you very bravely we stood up
and called the president out on that
very fact
but we also have seen as you said the
surge in violence against asian
americans in the past year
you described it amply here but the
discrimination is not new
right i mean there is a long history of
discrimination against asian americans
in the u.s beginning in the late 1800s
which actually came from the chinese
exclusion
act barring chinese laborers from
becoming
immigrants and then of course there were
the internment camps
uh during world war ii and then more
recently
in 1982 uh there was a real
case that shed light on this violence
there was a man named vincent chin
he was chinese but two white men mistook
him
as a japanese american and they were
angry because they
were losing manufacturing jobs to
japanese auto plants and so they beat
him to
death and that case got a lot of
attention but nothing really happened in
terms
of more protection for the community
because those two
suspects never served any jail time they
paid a very light
fee and again i think a lot of people
who look at the history
uh point to that as an example of a
missed opportunity
to show that you know this is
intolerable
you know ouija over the past week i've
had a chance to talk to asian american
pacific islander advocates i know you
have too
they tell me that this is a galvanizing
moment
and they also are saying that they
firmly reject
any notion that the motive in the
georgia shootings
has to be one thing or the other can you
talk about that ouija
right so the suspect says that he was
trying to eliminate a temptation because
he had a sexual
addiction and experts and activists say
that points to this idea
that asian women are disposable they are
objects because they have been
hyper-sexualized again for
quite some time in history and as a
result that
is a form of racism according to experts
and
activists who study this very thoroughly
we should hang for us we just thank you
it's really good to see you